I'd rather do it on camera no no no no
if it's on camera we're not doing an
interview why we'll explain why how do
you feel about that influence that you
have you better be careful we're coming
for your children there buddy about
Maring Nation yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
on my work it was a fabulous dinner
until you two uh mooned us thank God for
talk TV is not only the home of common
sense it's the only place where you get
the
[Music]
truth
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on PG uncensored live from
New York City Israel strikes hundreds of
Targets in Gaza as it stands on the
brink of allout War Hamas says more than
400 Palestinians are dead can the US and
the world do anything to prevent chaos
in the Middle East I'll talk to Chris
Christie plus more Pro Palestinian
protests stir unrested major to cities
and universities they have a right to
free speech but are they fueling a rise
in anti-Semitism we'll
[Music]
debate live from New York this is pi
Morgan
uncensored well good evening from New
York City and welcome to PE Morgan
uncensored whichever way you look at it
the world suddenly seems a much more
dangerous place and in the days and
weeks to come it's only going to get
worse Israel stands on the bring of
allout War on two fronts more than half
a million reservists and Personnel are
about to hammer Hamas in the west and
defend the country potentially from
Hezbollah in the north two different
terrorist groups into two different
territories both backed by Iran a sworn
enemy of the West Iran doesn't believe
Israel has a right to exist it wants to
encircle the country with paramilitary
groups and ultimately dominate the
region like all parah states it profits
from chaos and so far on that scale it's
winning Israel's massive strides towards
peace with the Arab world are suddenly
on ice but the whole region is red hot
again and no matter how much people want
to make this a simple story of good
versus evil of power and revenge the
fact is the stakes couldn't be higher or
the situation more
complicated we're in a battle for our
lives a battle for our home this is not
an exaggeration this is the war it's a
do or die they need to die we are now in
a double battle one b ATT is a battle to
hold action here and on the other side
to win there an absolute victory that
will erase
Hamas well on that Netanyahu may be
right this could be an existential
threat to Israel and the conflict could
seow chaos across the world that's why
it's a complete shambles frankly that
the United States currently has no
speaker of its house and no easy way of
approving either military support for
Israel nor aid for Gaza both are needed
urgently the Republicans need to get a
grip
the deaths of so many Palestinians
including hundreds of women and children
since the Hamas and Terror attacks that
of course they're heartbreaking and with
any ground Invasion it's going to get
exponentially worse Hamas will
inevitably used civilians as human
shields in Gaza it's already firing
Rockets from the cover of schools and
Moses and un buildings the potential for
deadly mistakes is massive every tragedy
WIll Stoke anger and resentment already
is boiling over on our streets reports
of anti-Semitism are soaring across the
world I've been struck by a number of
Jewish people I know in London and New
York who say they simply don't feel safe
this weekend saw more Pro Palestinian
protests in many major cities ignorant
campus protesters again condemned Israel
but stay silent about the atrocities of
Hamas in Brooklyn here in New York
people tore down posters of Israelis
kidnapped by terrorists and demanded
settlers go back
[Music]
home back Palestine is our home
Palestine is our home go back home go
back home Palestine is
our well in London crowds of segregated
rall is called for Jihad what is the
solution to liberate people in the
concentration camp of palestin what is
the
solution what
fight in the way of Allah those who
fight you theion entity has a they have
a police force they have a Judiciary
they have an and army fighting killing
massacring our people Islam
says that the Muslim armies move to
rescue the people of pales that is the
solution well the Met police says that
word has different meanings and it's
found no evidence of an offense but what
is a Jewish Londoner living in that
neighborhood supposed to think a London
Underground train the driver did
this palese fre pales hope you will have
a blessed day today look after
yourself a to
everybody and keep all those people in
your prayers have a good
day again imagine being a Jewish
passenger on that train today the
Israeli government showed foreign
journalists the unedited footage of the
terror attacks committed by Hamas in
October the 7th because the Instinct
incredibly of many people has been to
just deny they ever happened although
they were wildly exaggerated is that
really what this has come to every war
makes the world a more dangerous place
but that shouldn't apply to ordinary
Jewish people trying to go to work and
go to school none of whom has any
control over what Israel does next
they're no more responsible than the
Palestinian civilians caught up in this
Onslaught by by Hamas one thing we
should all be able to agree on is that
the innocent people in Gaza running out
of food and water living in constant
fear for their lives they've done
nothing either to deserve the hell
they're currently in the whole point of
terrorism is to fuel hatred Division and
disorder and right now that's exactly
what the terrorists are
doing well first T night the Israeli
Defense Forces showed a 100 journalists
in Tel what they say is unitive footage
of the Hamas Terror attacks to counter a
spade of denials one of those in
attendance was Jam confino a Spanish
journalist working in Israel yam thank
you very much indeed for joining me tell
me about what happened today aund
journalists including you were taken to
see unedited raw footage of these Terror
attacks October the 7th what did you
see first of all good evening piers and
I just wanted to say first of all that
I'm Danish um and I also want to of
course explain what it is that we it's
all right I want to say uh what is that
we saw today
um I think the best way to describe it
really is Isis on steroids uh the atroc
atrocities that we already know happened
and that we've already seen evidence of
by listening to eyewitnesses seeing the
scenes were now shown to us on a
screening 45 minutes of unra material
GoPro cameras from Hamas
terrorist um surveillance photo from
from kibuts SIM from small villages all
of it really really showing exactly what
happened I'm not sure how graphic I can
be Pierce cuz I would like to explain
what I saw but I don't want to uh you
know scare should just tell me what you
saw I don't I I honestly we're called
uncensored for a reason I don't think
this should be
censored absolutely and I absolutely
agree so first of all I saw a Hamas
terrorist throwing a hand grenade into a
bomb shelter where a man had father with
his two uh Sons were hi he was hiding
there then the father was killed
instantly the the two children ran out
disillusioned blood all over running
back to their home screaming for their
dad the the youngest boy who was roughly
seven couldn't see anything he said I
can't see and in the meanwhile the
terrorist who threw the grenade went
casually into the home opened the fridge
took out a bottle of water and drank it
and offered the kids some water as if
nothing had happened that was just one
scene we also saw of course the
beheadings we saw uh an Israeli soldier
lying on the ground beheaded and
terrorists uh around him screaming Alba
and cheering we saw Hamas Terrorist on
the streets
systematically assassinating people in
their cars executing them very very
close in close range we saw pictures of
uh a burned um child uh burned beyond
recognition you could all all you could
see was it as a very small person we saw
a picture of a dead baby with blood on
it we saw I don't even know I I had to
leave after 35 minutes because
eventually I had seen enough I knew that
this had has had had happened but
because of the severe backlash
especially on social media by people who
refuse to believe that this has taken
place despite the overwhelming evidence
I felt like I had to go there to see it
so I can tell people that I with my own
eyes saw it so if they don't believe the
eyewitness that I spoke to then they can
believe me because I'm a journalist and
I hope they still believe in what it is
that I'm
saying I mean I seen other reports from
other journalists there utterly horrific
also that many journalists were reduced
to tears watching it it was so uh
repellent to watch and so horrific um it
is extraordinary isn't it yam that we're
now in a place of misc conflict fueled I
think by disinformation on social media
where people are either ignorantly blind
to what has happened or deliberately
blind to what's
happened it's such a good question and I
think that it's absolutely outrageous
that journalists are now turned into
forensics they have to watch the most
horrific scenes that you can possibly
imagine in addition to speaking to
eyewitnesses in addition to being on the
scene seeing houses burned shattered
with RPG Rockets thrown into them blot
on the floor that is apparently not
enough you have to go now and see it I
I'm simply appalled that we've gotten to
the point that one of the most
covered Wars of the 21st century along
with the Ukraine war that we've gotten
to a point that we as journalists have
to sit there and watch 45 minutes of
onslaught it's simply Indescribable but
again people refuse to believe it and I
think we're going to make a small
difference I'm not sure that we're going
to convince everybody about what
happened here no I mean I saw your
tweets about this they were appalling
but incredibly detailed and immediately
I saw the reaction from uh people who
were already skeptical uh and it hadn't
changed their mind at all they just
thought it was all propaganda which is
incredibly dispiriting uh yam Cina thank
you very much indeed for joining me I
appreciate
it well coming up US presidential
candidate Chris Christie on what the
United States and the world should do
about the crisis in the Middle East how
far is proportionate in terms of
Israel's response to those Terror
attacks that's next on unsensed from New
York
City
[Music]
[Applause]
well welcome back to peers on censored
live from New York City I'm joined now
by the former New Jersey governor and
Republican presidential candidate Chris
Christie govern Christie great to have
you back on the program uh I wonder if
you could just start by giving me your
reaction to so the fact that a 100
journalists were taken into a room and
played unedited raw footage of these
Terror attacks on October the 7th
because so many people fueled by social
media are simply refusing to accept what
happened
happened look Pierce I think it's a
testimony as to what I've been talking
about for the past few weeks the rise of
anti-Semitism both here in the United
States and around the world is palpable
it's been palpable for some time and
it's in ining and we need to be speaking
out against that uh there is no other
reason um to be uh needing to show this
video except for people's disbelief
based upon anti-semitic views and
anti-semitic propaganda that has been
put out there not only across social
media but being put out in many of
America's colleges and universities uh
and this is disgraceful uh and it is
dangerous I mean it's this to to me
Beyond doubt that what happened on
October the 7th was one of the most
horrendous Terror attacks of Modern
Times And if you can't bring yourself to
express outrage over it there's
something wrong with you um but the
question now is what is a proportionate
response by Israel and I'm not sure what
the answer to that is other than already
within two weeks nearly three four times
as many Palestinian mainly civilians
have lost their lives in retaliation
strikes by Israel that number is likely
to massively increase if there is a
ground invasion is this proportionate do
you
think look Pierce I think the Israeli
Defense Forces and their government
should have three priorities here
priority number one is a a retaliatory
response against um Hamas that severely
degrades if not eliminates their
capability um of of striking against
Israel again number two should be
getting the hostages out as many of you
as them as you can um both American and
Israeli hostages that are being held Now
by Hamas Hamas and then third is to try
to have the response be seen as
something by the rest of the world as
setting the stage for conversations with
the rest of the Arab world about how
this type of conduct doesn't create a
peaceful situation in fact in fact
causes great great um harm to everyone
in the region and begin those talks
again and I think those should be the
three priorities an appropriate
retaliation the return of the hostages
and setting the stage for the next round
of conversations with Arab countries who
don't want to see this type of violence
perpetrated against anyone in the mid
East again I mean there are a lot of
experts uh who have long memories from
Iraq and Afghanistan
uh the response of course mainly by the
United States with with the British and
others uh to the terror attacks on 9/11
who believe that if we don't learn the
lessons from what happened there 20
years of Mayhem pretty much coming out
of our response that if Israel does go
in with a full-blown ground Invasion uh
then it could lead to a far more serious
situation than even the one we have in
front of us
now well Pierce look Israel has an
absolute right to protect both its
safety and its territorial integrity and
the only way to protect that safety and
territorial Integrity is to degrade the
capability of Hamas to do what they did
on October 7th again and the Israeli
Defense Forces are going to have to make
the judgment about what type of ground
force is necessary to protect the safety
and territorial Integrity of Israel but
that's got to be their goal and Mission
nothing nothing more nothing
less you're running for president uh
Donald Trump is still the front runner
uh many people think extraordinarily
given he's facing near a 100 criminal
charges um there's no doubt if you look
at Trump's record on as president in his
first term as somebody pointed out today
I think on social media Iran was hemmed
in by sanctions uh China by a trade War
Russia hadn't invaded Ukraine
Afghanistan hadn't Fallen to the Taliban
um now you see a lot of
turmoil um Trump never went to war
anywhere were we a more peaceful world
with Donald Trump as president of the
United States than we are
now well Piers I think that's a
superficial analysis of the situation I
mean the fact is that he said he was
pulling out of Afghanistan and that if
he had gotten a second term that's
exactly what he would have done um
secondly um he set up the circumstances
to give Russia the green light to go
into Ukraine in two ways one by his con
constant public coddling and kissing of
Vladimir Putin and two um by not giving
the ukrainians the weapons they needed
and in fact for a period of time
blackmailing the Ukrainian government
and president zinski in return for
getting dirt on Joe Biden for his
reelection campaign that hardly set the
type of posture that would make the
Russians think they should not be going
in there and as far as China's concerned
his quote unquote trade War this is a
guy who said he got the greatest trade
agreements ever with China and meantime
just in the agricultural space China
hasn't uh you know uh done
25% um of what they said they would do
and committed to in those trade Wars so
the idea that when he calls president X
brilliant and straight out of Central
Casting that that somehow deterred the
Chinese I think is a joke he also called
Hezbollah very smart what was your
response to
that that he's very
stupid and selfish and not only did he
call Hezbollah smart but he also then
went and gave a broadsided attack
against prime minister Netanyahu while
he's in the midst of Defending his
country in an existential conflict with
Hamas and he did it because uh Netanyahu
had the temerity to be sane and call Joe
Biden when it was clear that he had been
legally elected the president of the
United States and that's something that
Trump will never forgive and so what he
does is rewrite history um uh about the
solomani uh uh operation and other
things because in the end all Donald
Trump cares about is that you say he
actually won the election in 2020 and if
you didn't say that or you took actions
that contradicted that then you're his
enemy so now he's attacking Netanyahu in
the midst of a war he's calling
Hezbollah very smart it's because he's
very stupid and
childish I want to play you uh Governor
this is a clip of uh Benjamin Netanyahu
from an interview I did with him a few
months ago before all this happened in
which we talked specifically actually at
one stage about this concept of
collective punishment let's take a look
there have been 88 Palestinians and 15
Israelis killed so far this year it's
the highest rate of deaths in two
decades many are saying that a lot of
this is down to cury rhetoric from some
of your right-wing uh members of your
government and they particularly uh cite
uh bezel SMR in any case uh they're part
of my government but they're part of my
government and I uh I decide policy that
distance yourself from comments like
that uh there are many comments would he
call for the Palestinian town of aara to
be wiped out of of course not of course
I that's totally unacceptable we don't
believe in Collective punishment I go
after the terrorists I go after those
who support for the terrorists but I
don't believe in Collective
punishment now many people think what
we're seeing now Governor Christie is uh
Collective punishment that thousands of
completely innocent Palestinians are
getting killed as Israel tries to go
after Hamas who of course embed
themselves amongst the civilian
population like I said earlier that
number is only going to increase
exponentially if there's a ground
Invasion it's hard to see this is
anything other than an attack on
Palestinians in general because you
can't be selective can you in the way
that is being currently implemented by
Israel well the people who who say that
peers um I think believe that Hamas
should be rewarded for being
sneaky ra hamash should be rewarded for
doing a sneak attack on Israel killing,
1400 civilians and then going back and
hiding themselves among civilians and
thinking that by using them as human
Shields they're going to prevent Israel
from taking any retaliation I'm sorry I
don't agree with that um I think Israel
has to take the retaliation and if
Hamas decides to embed themselves with
civilians then those civilians complaint
is against the government they elected
not against the state of
Israel should Benjamin Netanyahu stay as
prime minister not withstanding there's
a war now the vast majority of Israelis
in the polls I've seen think he is
responsible what happened he always said
that protecting Israel and defending
Israel was his number one priority this
has been the biggest failure of Israeli
defense that uh we've seen in modern
times should he remain in
office uh look that's up to the Israeli
Parliament um and and what they do in
terms of a vote of confidence or no
confidence in their government but I
would say this that I think it's very
very dangerous to be changing
governments in the midst of an
existential War there's going to be
plenty of time peers um for there to be
an after action report about why Israeli
intelligence and other intelligence
agencies failed if they did and clearly
it seems they did to detect what H Hamas
was planning and how they were going to
execute it um and it may be that prime
minister Netanyahu has to pay a
political price for that failure but I
don't think the time to do it is now
Israel is facing a a threat to their
very existence to their territorial
Integrity that needs to be dealt with
first and any political issues that uh
prime minister Netanyahu has to deal
with because of failings that may have
occurred on his watch well then he could
deal with those after this problem is
put down Governor Chris Christie always
great to have you on the program thank
you very much
indeed well coming up are Jewish people
the only minority group the progressives
are indifferent to protecting alas of
founder the biggest Progressive channnel
in the world that very question that's
next to uncensored in New
[Music]
York we're here good morning
everybody hope you're well thanks for
joining us you're watching the
independent republic of Mike gra right
here on talk TV welcome to Friday night
with Nadine here on prime time we like
to speak to the business people behind
big moments good evening I'm Pi Morgan
uncensored in New York City very
impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just stared
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
tour today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating
I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going to take
the side of boozed up Brits against
these pomp you mean you're not going to
support mayor Jose L not stop pying to
the nimes to the naysayers and The
National Society for the preservation of
the habitat of the Lesser spotted M the
problem lies in the bureaucracy it's
almost like those highly paid
Consultants don't really know what
they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter use some
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with
us the one thing label would be
terrified of if Boris Johnson Zoom back
into full Focus Boris Johnson isn't what
he was most of them seem to have given
up welcome to the talk it's really great
to be back my Little Darlings kids think
all they have to do is stay at home be
silly take pictures of everything just
shut down Tik Tock then yeah yeah
problem
solve fit as a butcher's dog there you
go he's fit as a butcher's dog him all
right but but he's now middle class us
here test the knock on effect is far
larger than just CO2 I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
know you're probably going to boot me
after show
this call say I'm not I'm not a Swifty
critics I'd say me included got four PMS
all over the joint saying things the
last few days we have indeed yeah great
first show you having fun oh a ton of
fun King peers and King cute I think
there's only room for one king man you
know what I'm saying just cuz they're
skin folk don't mean they're kin folk
when I say I am good you think I'm
joking or not you tell me I'm not joking
I'd rather do it on camera no no no no
if it's on camera we're not doing an
interview why we'll explain why how do
you feel about that influence that you
had you better be careful we're coming
for your children there bu about Maring
Nation yes I'm going to do you're going
to resol yes cuz I cannot continue my
work it was a fabulous dinner until you
two uh Moon us thank God for talk TV is
not only the home of common sense it's
the only place where you get the
[Music]
truth this is talk
TV
welcome back to uncensored life from New
York City Pro Palestinian protest since
the Hamas Terror attacks of October the
7th of pilot of the chasm between
progressives and the Jewish Community
marches this weekend faced criticism and
police inquiries for pro HTH chants and
Banners students of major universities
including Harvard were accused of
anti-Semitism for a public letter
claiming Israel was entirely responsible
climate activist Greta thumberg posted
when deleted a picture pledging
unequivocal support for Gaza it's all
LED some commentators to ask why
aggressives and the left seem to stand
by all minorities except it appears
Jewish people what you me not to discuss
this the world's most influential
Progressive online Channel The Young
Turks and Democratic presidential
hopeful and that's Jen you go Jen great
to have you on the program thank you
very much inde for joining me I'll be
following your tweets with interest uh
this week you've been getting
increasingly uh Angry I think it'd be
fair to say he said I'm now enormously
frustrated by us and Israeli
government's barbaric acts in Gaza I'm
not be shy in sharing that opinion on
Piers Morgan show today um why are you
so
frustrated yeah well honestly I I didn't
expect the framing that you put on this
segment and it's a framing like that
that's disgusting so I don't see what
this has anything to do with
anti-Semitism I I formed Young Turks in
tyt with two Jewish friends who are some
of my friends growing up we've known
each other and been Brothers for over 40
years now so
I think what Hamas did is disgusting I
cry uh for those Israeli innocent
civilians uh but do I see you guys
crying for Palestinians I mean Chris
chrisy was just on here treating it like
it's no big deal because what
Palestinian lives don't matter I think
the real bigotry here is saying that
Palestinians we can kill three times as
many of them already and this is the
appetizer Netanyahu and his barbaric
government have not even started the
entree of murder and death and
they're about to do and that's somehow
okay killing three times as many
Palestinian civilians let alone the
occupation which is bigotry by
definition we say that everyone in the
world can uh defend themselves can have
their own State can have sovereignty
except the Palestinians and the
reasoning behind that is the
Palestinians are what are they're what
the idea is that they are savages and
that Muslims are too violent and cannot
control themselves so they must be
occupied for 56 brutal disgusting years
so I've had enough of the bigotry
against Muslims and Palestinians and I
need you to speak out against that
instead of covering every outrageous
atrocious action of the right-wing
government of Israel and go oh it's
anti-Semitism no when and there is
global anti-Semitism there's
anti-Semitism here in this country two
synagogues were shot up Pittsburgh and
in Southern California we fight against
that all the time but then when whenever
Israel is criticized you people go oh no
it's anti-Semitism no there's real
anti-Semitism instead of that instead of
attacking that all you guys ever do is
hide behind the veil of anti-Semitism do
you know why Palestinians might not like
Israelis because they've been oppressed
for 56 straight years I hate you I hate
and let me respond uh a I'm not you guys
I don't think I fit into any neat fit on
this issue at all um B I've actually
covered this story I think more fairly
than most people I've had many pro
Palestinian voices I've given a huge
platform for they've been getting
enormous audiences from Bassam youf to
others and I've done that quite
deliberately because I think these
voices I think these voices are
important to be heard including yours uh
I certainly wasn't accusing you by the
way or your organization of
anti-Semitism I just think I have found
it as somebody who's always identified
as liberal myself uh I found it very
dispiriting to see people who call
themselves liberals who've whose instant
response it seemed to me to one of the
worst Terror attacks we've ever seen was
to immediately side with the place where
these attacks have been launched from
now I don't tar all Palestinians with
the brush of being Hamas at all uh and
in fact the sooner Hamas are out of
there the better for the Palestinian
people and the world um but I just think
the only human response you can have is
as you did by the way to your credit is
it was disgusting what happened on
October the 7th now the question then
becomes what is a proportionate response
by Israel uh not just of a terror
attacks of October the 7th but obviously
there is now a huge ongoing escalation
in what has been as you rightly say a
56e uh War effectively in varying
degrees over that period and that's
where I think I I I'm struggling to see
how ground Invasion by Israel with all
that that would entail particularly Mass
deaths of Palestinian civilians how that
is going to do anything for any peaceful
resolution to this I think it will have
the opposite
effect yes so let's say it one at a time
first of all as you rightly point out on
Young Turks uh we covered uh the
atrocious actions of Hamas right from
the GetGo and we condemned it as fully
as anyone can possibly condemn it
because not only are they killing those
poor innocent Israelis that didn't do
anything
those little babies and the grandmothers
it's disgusting what they did but on top
of that they' they're ruining the
Palestinian cause they've burned the
moral High Ground to Cinders and then on
top of that they smear all people of
Muslim background like myself and and
and then it leashes this unleashes this
bigotry of anti-muslim bigotry
throughout the world I'm sick of so
screw Hamas and their barbarism okay now
in terms of a proper reaction
yes you need to get those hostages out
so now let's look at what I'm going to
suggest what to actually do I'm going to
be constructive but first let's look at
the unconstructive solution that Israel
had dropping bombs on residential
buildings 50 ambulance ambulances have
been hit 10 out of 25 hospitals don't
operate anymore the incubators are about
to run out of energy there's 45 babies
that might die today the parents I just
read on CNN are writing the names of the
kids
on their calves on their legs so that if
they are killed in a bombing and they're
mutilated they could find their bodies
imagine writing the name of your child
on their legs so that you could find
them in the rubble after Israel or any
government drops a bomb on them and I
need the West to understand something
bombs kill people and do you know how
they kill people they incinerate them
alive or their heads explode so what
happened in Israel was a was a disaster
and disgusting but you have to be
equally honest and it and equally
outraged at the immorality of
incinerating babies and grandmothers and
aunts and uncles which is what we're
doing right now America canot keep
sending aid for death and destruction
enough of the occupation end it today
end it today it's monstrous okay I'm
going to let me ask you this solution
let me a I completely understand your
pass passion and your anger I completely
get
this I like you want to see some
resolution at the end of this horror
that we're
witnessing how do you get rid of Hamas
if you don't do it the way Israel are
currently doing it how do you actually
eradicate what has become a nihilistic
Isis style terror group who've quite
deliberately in my estimation committed
an outrage of such appalling scale that
they knew that this would go Israel into
Mr kind of response so why they did that
what is motivating it who might be
putting them up to it who's helped them
prepare for this these are all questions
we don't know the answers to yet but it
seems to me that Israel could if it's
not careful be being lured into a
massive trap here and I I hope that is
not the case but I'm curious how do you
get rid of Hamas if you don't do it the
way Israel is currently doing it albeit
with horrific collateral damage in in in
the in the in the face of thousands of
innocent Palestinians being caught up in
the
buming yeah so let me give you
short-term answer long-term answer and a
lot of people are not going to like
these but these are realistic ways that
you minimize minimize civilian
casualties you do what America did with
the Osama Bin Laden raid we didn't go
drop a nuke on Pakistan we didn't go
destroy 6,000 residential buildings in
the middle of Pakistan we sent in
Special Forces is it more dangerous to
the special forces of course that's the
point of Special Forces try to find the
hostages does it look like Israel is
trying to find the hostages if I have a
family member that's a hostage I'm
disgusted what by what nyaho is doing
now how do you know they're not in the
buildings you're dropping bombs on how
do you know they're not in the tunnels
you're dropping bombs on how do you know
they're not in the hospitals you're
dropping bombs on so this if you want
the hostages rescued every rational
human being can agree this is not the
way to do it this is the way to do death
and Destruction for the sake of death
and destruction it's Collective
punishment it's genocide against
Palestinians and the world has to speak
out so my way is not pleasant either it
involves a lot of folks dying on uh on
both sides I understand that those are
super hard choices but go find Hamas go
find the hostages go rescue them incent
of wanting L int
indiscriminately killing after killing
and let's be honest when you drop a bomb
and and a and a kid's head explodes and
a grandmother is incinerated that is
Terrorism killing three times as many
civilians as
Hamas is
Terrorism and it is the same if it is
done by a government send in as many
special forces as you got we should send
look send in whatever you got to
actually do the job at hand instead of
what you're what Netanyahu is doing
which is to to kill these people to what
send a message and think about how
unrealistic that is and think about why
his chance his method has a 0% chance of
working how are the Palestinians
supposed to rise up against Hamas how
would they prove they're against Hamas
Hamas ended all elections Hamas ended
democracy so how are the Palestinians
supposed to cry Uncle they're already
crying uncle but it's never enough for
the bloodthirsty Netanyahu no more death
of Palestinians more babies killed
that's what his answer is and it's this
and the United States of America I'm
running for president here there's no
way in the world I would allow this
sending $15 billion dollar that's and it
doesn't even go to Israel Ukraine or
Taiwan it goes to the defense
contractors that are get that bribe
these greedy American politicians and
then get most of that money and so the
long-term answer is 1967 borders and the
biggest walls you've ever seen in your
entire life and no one's allowed to
cross to either side but the
Palestinians get their state it is
unconscionable for them not to get their
state and if you're a moral person you
of course you believe that the
Palestinians are not the only people in
the world that cannot govern themselves
if you say that you are being by
definition bigoted and a racist we have
to have two-state solution immediately
immediately if 56 years of occupation
and brutalizing these people is not
enough is 57 years going to be enough is
156 years going to be enough I'm asking
Israel not out of hate out of love so
many of my friends that I grew up with
are Jewish this is is not good for them
this is not good for anybody please look
into your hearts look and be the moral
people that I know you can be I've been
to Passover dinners where you pray for
your oppressors now I breaks my heart
but I got to tell you you got to pray
for those you are oppressing and to say
that you are not oppressing the
Palestinians after brutalizing them for
56 long years you're kidding yourself
and as a friend and an ally I'm trying
to get you to wake up and snap out of
this trans you cannot keep doing this it
is ruining your moral
fiber Jen Yuga thank you very much
indeed for joining me I greatly
appreciate I'm sorry it was your first
appearance on this program under these
circumstances but I hope it won't be
your last I think you're an important
voice in this and I do appreciate you
coming on the show thank you very
much thank
you on S next my Pat will assemble live
from New York City and debate these
interviews we've just been doing uh
there's a lot of passion a lot of anger
in this crisis let's have that debate
after the
[Music]
break
[Applause]
[Music]
e
coming up on the talk should ministers
toughen extremism laws in the wake of
pro Palestinian Jihad chance plus wish
she soon that calls time on migrant
hotels and Cambridge University triggers
a backlash After blacklisting books
considered a expensive that's all at
[Music]
9:00 welcome back to pbor sensored live
from New York City I'm joined Now by my
New York Pat the former US Navy SEAL the
man who killed Asama Bin Laden Rob Neil
the founder of the brand new media UK
Dan Abrams and the former conservative
MP Louise menel Stella pack if ever
there was one Dan I watched you having a
a pretty tense debate actually with Jen
yugar last week before he came here he's
passionate he's angry I get it he's well
informed he's articulate and he's
frustrated by what he sees as a double
standard what is what's your response to
what you just heard so I I I think that
you can take some of what he's saying
and saying he can make Fair points about
Palestinian civilians right concerns
legitimate concerns for how far Israel
goes how careful Israel is Israel ought
to be watched carefully Israel ought to
be scrutinized carefully but what he's
not doing is talking about the instances
where Israel let's say has to bomb in a
civilan area because that's where Hamas
is firing from right that's the
difference is he talks about well you
know it's like finding Osama Bin Laden
it's not there was Afghanistan first
right it didn't just out of nowhere
start with oh let's just go find Osama
Bin Laden oh you know what yeah it'll
take a little work some special forces
will go in there that was a Herculean
task to find Osama Bin Laden and credit
to the people who were ultimately able
to achieve it but it's not just like oh
you could send in some special forces
and go find them is he right about the
concern about hostages sure yeah there's
a real concern that hostages are going
to potentially end up getting killed
here but big picture Israel is trying to
avoid civilian casualties why do I say
that because it's bad for them it's bad
for their image it's bad for
international support you can say
they're not careful enough but the idea
that it's all indiscriminate and they're
just going to go and bomb all these
different places and not care about it
it doesn't even make sense but what is
proportionate I mean I'm I'm wrestling
with this right morally I'm wrestling
with this because I have a lot of people
on the Palestinian side there's a lot of
Arabs around the world who bombard me
with what they perceive to be the West
double standard on this how can you say
it's proportionate say within two weeks
four 5,000 Palestinians have already
been killed and it will like massively
increased with a ground Invasion what is
proportionate to the deaths of 1500
people yeah so I don't know the answer
there is no answer that's not the way
War works right the you don't say well X
number of people were killed and as a
result that means X number allowed on
the other side it depends what the other
side is doing the facts matter what's
happening on the ground is relevant it's
relevant that Hamas is intentionally
trying to prevent the Palestinian people
from leaving why because they want human
Shields they want want civilians to die
it's good for their political cause for
civilians to die it's the reason they
won't let 500 Americans Palestinian
Americans who are in the area leave why
they want human Shields and that's the
difference so when you ask the question
which is a fair question about what's
proportionate it depends on each and
every bomb that goes off let me bring it
Rob there's no one better to ask about
that comparison with Sama Bin Laden
you're the guy that shot and killed
Asama Bin Laden that was anal
Ops operation with Navy SEAL Team Six
obviously but as Dan rightly said it
followed a massive war in Afghanistan
for many years Joe Biden's already
warned let's not make the same mistakes
we made after 911 rushing into countries
having Urban Warfare which ends up
perhaps creating more problems than we
had to start with you look at Iraq and
you think well that led to Isis which
led to all sorts of hell for two decades
what is your take on where we are now
with this well Dan was right it took 10
years after 9/11 to do the mission to
get Bin Laden I mean they found Bin
Laden probably before that but then just
to get the target package how we're
going to get that what we're going to do
we're always trying to uh limit the
amount of Civilian casualties there as
well but it takes a long time it's not
as simple as let's just send Special
Forces like it's a video game that
doesn't happen at all plus Hamas is
committing the war crimes right now by
strapping people to to the missiles that
they're going to launch they want the
human seals like Dan was saying that's
what they're doing and you can't the
hardest part of a hostage rescue is
finding out where they are I'm one of
the few people that have been in a a
hostage rescue that worked we knew where
Captain Phillips was we don't know where
they're keeping them they have 300 miles
of caves they're 100t deep you have to
find all that out before you go in there
and they're going to be booby tra we
know that stuff's going to blow up but
it's it's not that simple um is is what
Israel's doing now is this proportionate
do you think to what happened I mean
obviously we were all horrified by what
happened on October the 7th it was
horrific as people have pointed out
proportionally it was like 10 times 9911
in terms of the death total of Israelis
but people around the world are getting
very jittery about the scale of Israel's
response and they realize this is just
the the warm-up to what could be a
massive they're playing into hamas's
hand they want the uh they want the
pictures of the people getting killed
that they put in front of the Intel
places that they have and the weapons
that they have because it's they know
the world's going to play with Hamas on
this and they're doing it on purpose but
if Hamas wants Israel to overreact as
people see it like this what's the
bigger plan here for Hamas well do what
they do just tell the media and let them
report from Hamas Hamas is going to tell
them what they want to do and a lot of
the media right now they don't need the
truth they just need to be first
reporting what it is it's bad it's a I
mean you know there are good people
everywhere this this is hamas's game I
mean if you want to take out the
leadership of M you'd probably have to
go to like Oman or or Cutter stuff like
that that's where the leadership is I
mean I think the media role of Mr F we
saw immediately in the aftermath of this
Hospital getting uh bombed the other day
that mainstream media from the BBC in
the UK to the New York Times here
rushing to say pretty well this was is
an Israel air strike it now looks
increasingly likely not definitive but
increasingly likely it wasn't it was
almost certainly a group inside Gaza who
were firing at Israel yeah I think it's
as definitive as you can get President
Biden said he has this Exquisite
intelligence from the Department of
Defense but as you rightly say these
aren't influencers and bloggers these
are supposedly Blue Chip news
organizations that we are supposed to
trust CNN the BBC the New York Times and
what happens they just want to be first
so if anything I think the bias is
entirely in the other direction all we
had was the Fig Leaf of the Palestinian
health authority which is by the way
entirely controlled by Hamas says this
that's not good enough it's better to
wait to let the facts emerge for example
all they needed to do with a hospital
was just wait until the sun came up then
they would have seen that as a matter of
fact it wasn't bombed or hit all media
is is a fantastic site I look at it all
the time and you you come to the UK obv
y it's the fog of War has come to the
media now in a way we've never seen I
mean the amount of disinformation fake
videos editting clips so on is
everywhere it's so hard to get to the
but this is why Louis's point is
important which is that means the
obligation on the topend media entities
is even higher right because of
everything that's out there I mean even
look at the numbers that are cited right
X number of Palestinians where's that
coming from from the Palestinian Health
Ministry right from Hamas that combines
even if you take their numbers at face
value people who die with people who are
killed Etc now again getting into the
minutia of the numbers I don't think
that's particularly useful but there is
way too much treatment in the United
States media and I think to some degree
in the British media of treating Hamas
like an equal partner when it comes to
gathering information well the
Palestinian Health Ministry says I mean
it seems to me I've got to say most
people I talk to Rob think hamash should
go right that they have become because
of this unbelievably Redline Crossing
terror attack on October the 7th they
it's simply Unthinkable they continue to
rule the roost in Gaza the question
becomes how do you get rid of them from
a military perspective is it the smart
play by Israel to go in as a ground
Invasion or is the smarter play to have
a load of people like you Special Forces
highly trained going in and picking them
off in smaller groups well I mean the
unfortunate truth is if you want to get
to the to the end game and cutting off
the head of the snake as they say it's
in Iran and so you need to get rid of
the the funding from there because
Iran's proven they don't even care if
it's Hamas hezb that escalates it into a
it's terrible too and that's the lead
like I said in Gaz if you were trying to
get rid of well you need you need to
crush a us no doubt about it and and
what's the best way to do that the best
I mean the best way is is uh if it
didn't start in the first place but
there's been a war there since you know
Biblical times um um the best way to get
rid of it in the long term is to stop
teaching kidss to hate each other that's
that's the the the first way the second
way is you have to go in there and hit
him as hard as you can and basically
wipe himas out unfortunately in a ground
Invasion yeah it has to happen I mean
they've tried it before they tried it
Hamas right now is not interested in the
two-state solution and so you no they're
interested in killing as many Jewish
people as I can Poss unfortunately it's
all the the innocent lights are getting
lost there's got to be a better way
around it but right now it's bombs and
bullets I mean the politics of this
can't be ignored I mean Netanyahu is
incredibly unpopular amongst Israelis
most of them hold him accountable for
this stratospheric failure of security
and defense by the country sure should
he keep his job will he keep his job
absolutely not um most people in America
don't know that Benjamin Netanyahu sent
um half a billion dollars of Aid of
which 50% is estimated to have gone to
Hamas now it's not an anti-israeli
propaganda that came from haret the
Israeli newspaper they said look at this
Alliance that BB n he was happy he was
happy to have Hamas in charge because he
to think his is untenable I I complely
agree with you and the reporting is that
the military leaders in Israel want to
see him gone obviously he didn't cut off
those babies heads but he is in charge
of the defense of Israel and he was so
concentrating on the Supreme Court that
he allowed this to happen Dan what does
Victory look like for Israel here you
know look it's not going to look like
what we're hearing from Israeli leaders
right it's not going to be the end of
Hamas Hamas isn't going to end as a
result of this Victory from my
perspective would be a good number of
Hamas leaders killed a good number of
the hostages rescued honestly I don't
know how else to to quantify it there's
not a number I can put on any of that
but if you can get a good number on each
on each of those then that's then that's
to some degree of Victory but there's no
way that this is going to end in a
perfect I don't think there are winners
here and is going to going to be scale
of lost uh thank you to all of you what
a fascinating conversation it's such a
difficult situ
isn't it and I just don't see any simple
way through this the sadness is of
course it's a time when the region had
appeared more stable than it had been
for a long time and that's one of the
great great yeah of course great to see
you thank you very much indeed I
appreciate it that's it for me whatever
you're up to Keep It Uncensored good
[Music]
night
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in New
York City very impressive well played
I'm three days into the job what have I
done wrong and your face just starred
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
tour today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
Rich she I'm so rich frankly uh I'm
going to take the side of boozed up rits
against these pomp you mean you're not
going to support mayor Jose
l stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like there
highly paid consults don't really know
what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients be
patient with
us the one thing labor would be
terrified